what's happening
you look younger than when I last saw
you you because I was fat or less son oh
you've shed into Mel B's yeah a little
bit not a lot but I was definitely
fatter I was about 20 pounds heavier and
what did he do
um I took a bit yep bunch of fatter men
white collar guys woke up on Wednesday
night like we all got hot wives we got a
shape up like I thank you $1,000 no way
the town we live it we got some cash I
got a trampoline yard this is so not
Mimi's like everybody those are good
comedy whines the Malbec you don't hear
as well that's right yeah well I like a
nice dry white so there you go I know
when you guys are dog you give me a
shark never dry string any day of the
week right leg uh sounds red doesn't it
yeah
so where where are we what are we doing
this is not another podcast where we
start yeah I don't know where we want we
just supposed to go straight make a left
and I made a u-turn and I don't know
where I'm at you mean Oh in the
interview oh I understand ha ha ha ha
well wake up and I'm not quite sure but
keep choking along
turning up a little safe guys they are
there oh who and what is having white
wine keep mervich I love it
did you see the cars last night I would
love to see Cosby because he was a huge
inspiration for me yeah of course me too
I love the car did you ever get to talk
with him I've never heard em say [ __ ]
without you have yes I'm the REIT since
2008 I started doing a cleaner I'll
click on yeah I was also struggling
because I am the you're the half a guy
that's an alibi I was kind of trying to
appeal to that audience and then out of
nowhere they said Cosby was come on do
your radio show and was he promote
nothing what is he what why did he just
wants to come on his show meet me the
guy he wants to make and I had a
conversation with him and he goes on
this is how he starts a conversation he
goes yes hello so the reason I'm talking
to you
and he went he asked me said I want you
to read a chapter in my book cause
biology he's giving you everything like
yeah I have a reading lesson so now I
got homework and I read the faxes it to
me the chapter says the day I quit show
business
oh wait oh my oh my god yeah but as the
as a chapter went on it said how he when
he started he tried to appeal to an
audience that he wasn't and not until he
realized this is what
I really want to talk about and don't
fear that then you will leave the
showbiz you become yourself and they
will come to you and yeah I couldn't
have heard that from a bigger influence
I really need to hear that at that time
and that boom I set up a tour a
university tour of all teenagers because
I thought if I can overcome then then
the family is going to be easy so crappy
was a huge personal influence we can't
believe that that's appearing it was
weird and it he he would say something
like this and go uh he comes on the show
he goes you are a fat child yes as it
yeah 82 pounds in kindergarten 82 hours
were you stupid and I went oh boy
no it's actually the king of my black
heels aha so was Fat Albert and they
wanted that's right he goes they wanted
him to be stupid and I said fat people
aren't stupid he will be the leader and
I've been struggling with people's
opinions and how they want to pigeonhole
ders the rest of my life and I will do
it for the rest of my life as you will
to get a sword an idea